can spider-man come out to play all
right we have a new trailer for
spider-man no way home which looks like
a soft sinister sex movie when the home
word play in the spider-man title would
sell more tickets than the sinister six
title
we're imploding the reveal of the last
trailer was like oh hey doc ock and
goblin bomb now they're like all right
now you know so bring on that concept a
lot of villain footage doctor strange in
this trailer's like you know when you
screwed up that spell i was trying to do
for you peter that time you did that
peter should have been like you remember
that time you were [ __ ] with the
multiverse at my behest only at the very
last moment to tell me oh by the way
mj's gonna forget about her love for you
remember that mr informed consent doctor
how long have you not been a doctor that
you forgot about informed consent it's
official you're no longer a doctor
you're just named strange but it looks
to be the main point in this movie is
that all these new villains from other
spider-man universes from the movies
that we've seen have come to this
universe and so doctor strange is like
well their fate is to die
so they just kind of have to die
which means you have to kill them which
is pretty dark peter parker's life is
it's a strange one not only did tony
stark recruit a minor without the
consent of his guardian the doctor
strange is telling this minor yeah you
gotta murder people
sucks to be you i guess he didn't
actually say spider-man needs to kill
them but it's implied because he said
spider-man killed them in their
realities so to be fair green goblin's
death was green goblin's fault all
spider-man did was jump out of the way
well i guess also doctor octopus wasn't
killed by spider-man he went out a hero
you know i will not die a monster and
went down saving everybody maybe strange
is gonna be like all right you're right
i'll kill them just stab em away that is
a strange kind of heart but now
basically this trailer is to show you
some good looks at the villains that
they have in this movie i mean well
glimpse of the lizard you only see a
glimpse of him but you do see sandman
which you saw some dust and some dirt in
the last trailer and this one's like no
that's full sandman plot twist he's
actually here to help peter parker he's
like wait dad what what are you talking
about i didn't die you know what i'll
help you spiderman yeah [ __ ] these guys
i'll fist pump them with my big rock
hand just because they were dumb enough
to get killed doesn't mean i can't be
smart enough to live i do like how
electro like the lightning forms that
electro mask shape on his face dr
octopus gets captured so he looks like
hannibal octopus but i have no reason
why they're making fun of his name what
was your name again dr otto octavius
doc ock should have been like all right
first of all you work for a guy named dr
strange so dr otto octavius not that
strange i don't know why i keep doing
that when i say the word strange but dr
otto octavia should have been like yeah
you're gonna make fun of names now penis
parker
right when the nerds become the bullies
we get a good look at willem dafoe as
the green goblin looks exactly how i
remember he's so good it's the green
goblet i thought this was the moment
where it's like you don't have to have
the mask because he's willem dafoe he
looks perfect at max
max what you have to do is just spray
his face green but he does still have
his goblin mask i'm personally i'm just
looking forward to the official hot toy
release of his figure i mean come on i
will say there's this one scene where
goblin flies past the camera and that's
a new goblin outfit at least new goblin
outfit possibly different goblin
character whoever it is doesn't have the
mask and so maybe that is willem dafoe
without the mask so like yeah we'll
start out with the mask make it all
familiar then we'll do costume changes
later on maybe it's one of the different
goblins like you know ned leads from
this other universe like oh i'm your
best friend here i'm actually an enemy
of yours in another universe
sucks to be you but a really interesting
thing in this trailer it shows that in
this movie spider-man and
strange i'm not gonna do the thing
they're at odds with each other because
doctor strange is like they need to die
peter parker's like that's dark i don't
think so i don't like that dr strange
just punches his soul his spectral form
out of his corporeal form and mj does
what spider-man's girlfriends do
which is fall from great heights all in
all i thought it was a great trailer no
glimpse of toby or andrew sorry but
there are implications that other
spider-mans have been edited out of
scenes that they might be in like that
shot's a pretty wide shot for one
spider-man i guess there's footage
online of that shot where it looks like
the lizard just gets kicked in the face
by nothing wasn't in the trailer i saw
but still what's the lizard jumping at
exactly like the other two are like
spider-man lizards like best buy has a
ps5 in stock i'm on it he's not jumping
to spider-man spider-man's over there
lizard's like yeah
so there are things like that in this
trailer that make you go fun theorizing
and observations aside i'm not pinning
my hopes on toby maguire and andrew
garfield showing up to play i'm taking
this movie as its pitch to me as i'm
seeing it in the trailers as advertised
tom holland spider-man needs to solve
this problem of the sinister five all i
know is at the end the multiverse starts
really fracturing it's like oh [ __ ]
sylvie's alright the spider-man no way
home trailer have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know i also have a
link to the trailer below because i do
that when i talk about trailers makes it
convenient for you and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you